so yeah as as we said I am data
scientist working in the British Museum
but I'm not gonna be talking about any
of that today sadly I am talking about a
personal project related to literature
and novels and the kind of fun stuff
that you can do with them that is maybe
a step away from to traditional NLP
scary stuff we need them like sorry we
need to hear your lovely voice our
machine earned for natural language
processes are not working our human ears
don't work as well how's that thank you
doctor yes so as we said I am a data
scientist working at the British Museum
I'm not going to talk about any of that
just gonna go over some fun results
related to novels and the stuff you can
do with them so even though I have a
background in machine learning
no neural networks know machine learning
no nothing like that in this talk also
nothing useful for work hopefully you'll
go away and have learn nothing that
you'll be able to apply but there's some
interesting results in here hopefully
you will enjoy them Who am I I'm these
things you can add me in these ways I
did physics I'm doing date science the
the worm story kind of starts with
Infinite Jest which is a massive massive
book with hundreds of characters and
storylines that all kind of overlap it's
a very complicated beast of a novel to
read but there are lots of useful
resources out there for people who are
trying to attempt this thing including
this enormous map by a guy called Sam
Potts which is lovely it's a map of
characters this was put together by hand
by Sam and all of these points are
characters in the novel and they are
connected by their connectedness if you
see an edge between two characters that
means that they they have some kind of
relationship and I found that when I was
reading the book I went back to this
quite often to try and keep track of who
was what and where and what they were
related to how important they were to
the story
and I was thinking can i duplicate that
programmatically is there some way that
we can take any novel and extract its
characters and put together some big map
like this it's it's a potentially useful
thing in a lot of ways if you're coming
to a new novel a big novel or whatever
but it also gives you a nice intuitive
way of approaching graph theory network
analysis it gives you a comfortable
frame to explore all of these concepts
in so yeah the idea is that we're going
to go from this or if things were in the
US to something like that which is a
network of Harry Potter characters they
are all kind of colored by their their
grouping which has also been
automatically extracted so yeah the
answer to the question is yes this is
doable programmatically all the code is
here you can go and find it you can go
and play with it it's a lot of fun so
start we need to find connections
between character names but involves
scraping a load of text from a novel and
taking names first loading in a book is
super simple code is on the screen
anyone can do that passing in a list of
names the easiest way to do this is to
pass an explicit list of names to to
explicitly tell bookworm who the
characters are in your novel that you
care about and then from there you can
go and build this network but it's not
really automation you can't really call
that an intelligent program if you're
giving it a load of context beforehand I
wanted a program that would
automatically take in any novel and spit
out this graph without any prior context
or knowledge so we needed to find
implicit names or plausible names in a
novel
I used a load of stuff from both spacing
and n LT K for this but it's just a
process that goes through every single
word in the novel works out whether it
is a proper noun whether it has a
certain length a load of very simple
checks on each word to see whether they
are plausible character name whether
they look like something that might be a
name
this kind of relies on authors adherence
to typical language yeah typical English
language but usually that works in what
I found so far the next thing to do is
split the book into a load of short
chunks and so we've got three versions
of that splitting here one which splits
into sentences so you might get a
sentence like this that uses LT K this
one splits it into words so you might
end up with a sequence like this or
characters it doesn't really matter
which one means you choose I usually go
for sentences because that includes the
most context but yeah it's up to you
which one you use there and then this is
the kind of secret behind bookworm and
how these graphs are formed basically
for every sequence every sentence in the
book it goes through and checks for
occurrences of character names so in
this example sentence it might pick out
but Vernon and Harry are characters tag
them and then build up a table that
looks something like this that says for
every character in the network do they
appear in each sentence and how many
times that ends up being an incredibly
sparse matrix but that's what we start
with
from there we build up an adjacency
matrix or co-occurrence matrix by taking
the dot product of that with its own
transpose so what we end up with after
this after taking the dot product of
this with itself
is a matrix of character names and
character names so character Ling names
along the top and character names down
the side and the number of times that
they co-occur in sentences that gives
you a measure of how related these
characters are and that's basically it
once you have an adjacency matrix you
can do all sorts of graph theory stuff
and network analysis that's where all
control that can be trivially trivially
transformed into something that's
interpretable by Network X which is a
fantastic Python library for network
analysis and broth theory stuff it takes
stuff in this form where you have a
character source a character target and
a value of the strength of the
connection between those two characters
as I said all of this code is on the
screen but it's also on github so don't
worry too much about reading at all so
we can pass this table into network X
and visualize it very very quickly with
Network X dot draw spring where spring
refers to the the idea that edges
between characters that the connections
are Springs with a kind of springiness a
strength related to that character
connectedness the value column there so
doing that we end up with something like
this and there is our graph we can see
that it kind of makes sense we have a
cluster up at the top of the Dursley
family you can also see that the
Weasleys are often clumped together you
might see that Voldemort is connected to
Harry and Firenze and Ron these things
kind of makes sense that graph there is
using the explicit named list that we
manually input we manually pass those
names to the network but this again very
similar has all of those same clusters
is done using the implicit names so
spoked purely
using their plausibility and yeah it
works surprisingly well we can do this
for any novel and I found it works on
pretty much anything
so here's Harry Potter here is Lord of
the Rings which is quite a lot more
complicated but again if you go and
inspect that it does make sense here is
Pride and Prejudice you can see that
these networks are quite different to
each other Harry Potter and Lord of the
Rings look much more similar they have
more similar features than Pride and
Prejudice which is a much more kind of
incestuous network where everybody
everybody knows each other and it's a
very small network whereas this is a
huge sprawling epic you can work out the
closest relationships of each character
to the rest of the network so Harry
Potter is most closely connected to Ron
Weasley Hylian Ian Hagrid you can work
out the character importance of every
character in the novel so in Harry
Potter unsurprisingly Harry Potter is
the most important character I did this
with the Bible the other day dot most
important Israel came second which is
interesting and Jesus third this is
using PageRank
this is hits two different algorithms
for assessing importance of nodes in a
network you can also find parts between
characters I don't know why this would
be useful but it's kind of interesting
to think about that maybe if you wanted
to connect Hedwig and Nicholas Flamel
this would be the path that you would
take between characters with the fewest
steps yeah that is the the kind of basic
stuff that you can do with a network
like this that's that the fundamental is
now we're gonna move on to some more
interesting stuff that is maybe more
specific to novels including time and
chronology novels or typical novels take
place chronologically they're written
down in sequence of how things happen
and you can chunk that up you can say
what happens in the first quarter of a
novel what happens in the second quarter
etcetera
etc yeah
and through that you can watch the the
character relationships develop and get
stronger get weaker and build up this
network over time which is quite
interesting to look at
temporal networks are a whole field that
I'm only just starting to explore but
it's super super interesting and if
you're interested in any of this I would
recommend going looking at that so this
is Harry Potter chunked into four you
can see that the first quarter of that
on the top left is quite small quite
closely connected Harry Potter's world
it's very small and sad and then he gets
the Hogwarts and his network expands he
meets more people more things happen and
then things kind of close down at the
end this approach where we're taking
chunks of the novel individually I'm
just looking at the first quarter by
itself the second quarter by itself is
one way of doing it but we can also
build up the novel over time so take the
first quarter than the first half and
the first three quarters and then the
whole thing at once and that's what this
looks like I think this is a much more
interesting visualization you can see
that growth through the novel which is
very nice you can do it in two more
chunks it's all very interesting um
gender stable marriages I don't know
whether anyone's heard of stable
marriages or stable marriage problem
it's a problem that comes from game
theory related to that the problem is
taking a bipartite graph so a graph with
two types in it I'm trying to match the
different nodes in those two halves
according to a list of preferences so
because we know the the strength of the
relationships between characters we
might be able to figure out who they
would prefer to be matched up to the
there is another version of this called
the stable roommates problem where you
a non bipartite graph just a singular
graph with one type of note and try and
match everybody to one other person to
maximise their preferences and so the
approach that I have had so far - this
doesn't involve actually extracting
gender I would really like to do that if
anyone has any tips on how to extract
implicit gender or implicitly attach
gender to a character named in a novel
hit me up but I haven't got there yet at
the moment I am just randomly assigning
gender to each character and then
matching so occasionally Harry is a girl
but that's fine oh that's sad
alright basically this works
half the time you will get characters
being assigned their correct gender and
in that case harry gets matched up with
Hermione most of the time that's nice
yeah the algorithm to solve stable
marriages is called Gale Shapley that's
that the pair of people who came up with
it I think this is gonna show us a
marriages of Harry Hermione um the last
thing but I'm gonna talk about oh no
second-to-last his community detection
which is a really interesting problem in
graph theory there's been a lot of talk
on clustering and closeness today using
your networks and various approaches
like that this is a graph theory based
approach which i think is really
interesting which i'm not gonna go into
detail of the the maths of that but it
uses the python Leuven module based on
the implementation of Blundell at all
and again it works
this is Infinite Jest if you have read
Infinite Jest you know that the novel
takes place in two kyv main storylines
and there are a lot of little adjacent
storylines that go along with that and
that's what we see here too
clusters of single colors and then
smaller clusters of other colors around
there this is Lord of the Rings I think
this is the second book because we've
got Pippin and Merry and Treebeard in
the ents up there yeah that's that here
is Harry Potter again you can see that
the Weasleys are often clustered
together the Dursleys
also clustered together you also get
teachers clustered together in this
which is nice and yeah finally graph
matching so given that we can assess the
similarity of characters in novels I
thought it might be interesting to try
and figure out the similarity of novels
to one another not based on any of their
language or their style or whatever but
just based on the shape of these
networks that we've built and the graph
matching problem is is a difficult one
one that is still being solved but as I
said earlier we we have these two
networks
paraquat some of the rings that are
quite similar to each other in in their
structure and then Pride and Prejudice
which is different using laplacian
spectra we can do this it works we
through this this technique using
Laplace ian's we can calculate a score
for each pair of novels where the scores
closeness to zero is a measure of
professor similarity so a novel match to
itself will get a score of 0 because
they are identical and a lower score
gives a measure of more similarity so
here with those three novels we can see
that Harry Potter and Lord the Rings are
more similar to each other they are the
more similar pairing and Harry Potter on
dragon Prejudice a lot very similar Erik
Bosse who wrote the Rings again not very
similar through that I'm hoping that we
can build a network of novels I really
would like to take a huge corporate of
novels that
the lighter witches is on Project
Gutenberg or the British library's
Google ebooks or Microsoft books thing
and ingest them all bookworm them all
and pull out this huge graph of novels
based on their character structure I
think that'll be really interesting
still in development don't know whether
it's going to work but if it does I
think we might be able to do some really
interesting stuff I have an idea about
genre I think that genre is probably
extractable from this the idea that we
can assess the similarity of fantasy
novels this is much more small character
driven ones and yeah and also there's an
interesting thing that I've been
noticing differences between um first
person and third person novels quite
interesting because in a first person
novel obviously the main character isn't
named explicitly you are i when you're
reading a novel that isn't picked up as
a character name so the character
networks look quite different but yeah
as i said i am getting somewhere with
the novel connectedness thing looking at
all of the Harry Potter's we can pull
out this heat map of sonority here the
the darkness of each cell represents
their similarity and by looking at all
of them together by essentially taking
the sum of each column of that heat map
we can figure out which one is the most
Harry Potter II if that makes sense
it's Harry Potter - Harry Potter - wins
Harry Potter five is the least Harry
Potter ebook based on his character
structure
that's basically it for what I've done
so far but there's a lot that can happen
in the future I reckon this probably
optimizable for HPC or high-performance
computing that they're finding
connections is trivially parallelizable
I think so if anyone wants to help with
that hit me up and yeah if that could be
done then we could apply this to massive
stuff more massive amounts of stuff um
again clustering genres or types of
novel I think would be really
interesting the idea of applying it to
historical stuff or biography basically
true novels I think is another
interesting application of this and
being able to detect bias in the way
that things have been written adapting
it for screenplays I think is also very
easily doable and and yeah
classifying new novels and seeing which
they are most similar to and maybe
coming up with some kind of
recommendation system or algorithm based
on that again all this code is on github
there don't find it come and contribute
talk to me that's it
any questions yeah can you give the EOI
five on what laplacian spectrum actually
does um are you familiar with eigen
vectors eigen values so you know that
they encompass some sort of when you do
the singular value decomposition of a
matrix of you come across that kind of
thing before the SVD returns a a sorted
list of of vectors based on the amount
of complexity that each vector
encompasses if that makes sense the
laplacian does a very similar thing so
what we're doing with the laplacian
where are we back here is taking a
taking the number of the number of
vectors which encompass the 90% of the
novel's complexity and then comparing
them for two novels I don't know whether
that makes sense but there is much more
writing about this on github and I can
point you to that next question there's
another one right there I think go for
that just for the sake of simplicity hi
I just have a question about source data
um so obviously there's like Project
Gutenberg and stuffs or older books kind
of where do you get data other than
something kind of cost prohibitive like
buying them on Amazon and then
converting that so I don't recommend
Project Gutenberg it's a fantastic
resource and there is some really
there's more contemporary stuff on there
than you might expect I also mentioned
the British Library and their resource
that they have that's all being OCR and
it was also added about 10 years ago
when computer vision was pretty nascent
and not very good so there's a lot of
flaws in there I'm still kind of
exploring how how applicable it is to
that dataset and whether we might need
to do some more cleaning stuff like that
but yeah there are a surprising number
of ways of getting hold of these
resources another question Thanks um so
you had two graphs in the beginning for
Harry Potter one using the explicit
names and using the implicit names if I
remember out on the implicit ones there
were many more dots around the edge yes
which I think means there's a lot more
weaker connections um so can you talk
about that why there's that difference
so the the connections themselves aren't
weaker it's still finding that basically
I impose a threshold a lower bound for
the relationships that are going to be
included let's go back to it here we go
so the difference here I think is mostly
to do with the plausibility of those
character names the implicit names list
also includes stuff like places so
Hogwarts might come up as a character in
the implicit names which itself is kind
of interesting it introduces a whole
load of weird effects like with
particularly big novels like Infinite
Jest or Game of Thrones things like that
at geography starts with starts to
emerge from that because characters are
all connected to places places a certain
distance from each other in this graph
space yeah I I'm not really sure how to
describe the the weakness of those
character names it's definitely a
problem that I'm interested in refining
but I think it's very interesting now
and the best way of getting to know it
is to just go and explore to apply this
to a few novels yourself and
get feeling for what those might be I
know you said you can extract genre from
this or you think you can have you ever
tried this on something nonfiction and
then like is the plan to do that and
then like determine how realistic novels
are I don't know about assessing the
realistic Ness but I yes I am starting
to think about how this can be applied
to nonfiction in particular biography
and maybe in situations where multiple
biographies of the same person or
multiple books about the same subjects
have been written assessing the
differences between them and maybe being
able to determine what kind of slant
each one has on that topic yeah another
idea I have is kind of similar kind of
different but taking reference books and
their indices and their indexes and
assessing the similarity of topics based
on that based on their proximity to each
other in the index and something to
explore there's another question over
here
how informative do you feel the applying
sentiment analysis to the sentences
would be in determining the
relationships between the characters or
do you feel like that would just be way
too noisy um
yeah again I think it's really
interesting I haven't done it yet but I
think it's definitely something worth
exploring the I think the strengths of
book 1 is that it doesn't do that it has
no idea about what sentiment is it it
only assesses strengths so to go back to
Harry Potter again just in it's a nice
illustrative example um Harry Potter
might be as close to Draco Malfoy as
Siesta Ron Weasley even though it's an
adversarial relationship between Harry
and Malfoy if it is strong if you're
requiring that networks that edges in
the network have some measure of
sentiment I think that limits it because
they were going to be much fewer exam
many fewer examples of sentiment in each
sentence he just asked my question
so like a friend foe or lover yeah I
again would really like to do that but
something that I'm still exploring for
now um there's one down at the front
not all so the question was how do you
process the dangerous sorry um how much
pre-processing am i doing in in this
process very very little that was the
whole idea was that I would just be able
to slam this set of algorithms over any
novel and output some kind of graph the
I think the cleverest bit of pre
person's pre-processing that goes on is
part of speech tagging which is like you
said some kind of pre-processing thing
but that's left entirely up to Spacey at
the moment I'm not doing any of that
myself and it's a relatively quick
process so it's it's very
labor-intensive for me any more
questions we have times yeah sorry I
know it's alright okay more of an
observation in the question I guess if
you thought about maybe applying the
sort of genre specifying aspect of this
and thinking about trying to categorize
things by when they're written or like
publication date because like this kind
of thing changes I'm sorry I'm a student
of writing is also this kind of thing
I'll often change over time like a
Dickens sort of a novel will have a much
more sparse matrix than a you know
something more written today so what I'm
hoping is that that kind of thing will
be emergent that I won't have to tag
things with your publication that it
will they will just cluster themselves
whether that happens or not I'm not sure
if it doesn't I will probably go in
tiger load of stuff with metadata just
to see whether things are clustering
together or not um but yeah but is
something that I'm interested historical
trends the way that writers from the
1800s compared to writers from the
nineteen hundreds and where the
character structure develops an
audience's taste yes thank you
do you do anything to make sure that you
don't have like one node for Harry
Potter and a different node for Harry no
not right now it's a real problem with
the implicitly network that often
characters do have multiple names with
explicit names it's very easy to tie
those together but with implicit names
it's quite hard to draw those
relationships and but often those things
won't matter with a lot of a lot of
characters because they because of the
the threshold that isn't bosz usually
they're only referred to by one name and
that name is emergence is the strongest
one the one that has the most
connections to the most people so that's
usually the only one that will be left
in it's only with very very prominent
characters in a network that that kind
of thing sticks around
Harrison what would the chart look like
if it was the DC Comics cuz I feel like
you know those movie makers are there's
so many interesting I don't know how you
would assess that how would you know
that computer vision to look for
character co-occurrence in similar
panels so I'm curious if you've thought
about characters who aren't represented
as proper nouns so for example in Cormac
McCarthy right two of the main
characters are the kid and the judge and
there could be entities and in novels
that important like an embassy or the
Union yes Oh have you thought about
educators like that and how you would
deal with that at the moment I am purely
enjoying the fact that some non
characters are appearing in the network
so some entities like you said like
Kings Cross might appear as a character
in the network trying to automatically
assess the character nurse of a word
that doesn't have these character like
attributes it's difficult if you have
ideas about that let me know um but yeah
very interesting it kind of is a similar
problem to the first person third person
novel thing but that in itself is
interesting I think that's it's worth
it's boring again but
you talked a little bit about splitting
up the books into different sections and
seeing how how the network sort of
morphed over time have you thought about
maybe sort of doing it the other way
around and having the morphing of the
network sort of define what sections of
the book are what lengths they are
things like that
good idea I'll go away and do that one
nice question this might be the same as
the question was just asked but as far
as like symbols and and places in books
what some books that sit over a little
heavy-handed on the symbolism and so you
have objects that sort of matter more
for that their role in the story than
just the individuals yeah um have you
thought about it looking for I guess
explicit symbols you know the
conch-shell over the over the course of
the book yes I haven't gone and explored
specific novels with that in mind I've
just kind of noticed it and the ones
that I have been working with but that's
a really interesting idea I would like
to grow this apply it to more and more
novels and don't find examples like that
but at the moment I haven't gone and
done that explicitly Thank You Harrison
for sharing your levels what Sangeeta
[Applause]